but you know in the 50s the working
class and the industrial working class
where the heroes in America that and
would they haven't been the heroes in
America for a long long time and and so
they're hurting in a lot of ways large
Kobe president of opportunity America
thanks for being here my pleasure of it
and we're here to talk about the report
that you were the driving force behind
work skills and community and you were
part of two and we had a lot of fun
doing it we did why did we do it and
what is it about it's about the working
class and I'm sure everyone remembers
campaign for in 2016 the working class
was all anyone could talk about there
was a there were furious sound bites on
every side of the campaign and a lot of
journalism but I don't think anyone
really got to the bottom of who these
people are and what their issues are and
when we as a group of scholars started
to look beneath all of this sound and
fury and sound bites we found that there
a group still somewhere between the
poorest of the poor and the middle class
but having troubles they used to look
like the middle class in all but income
range and now they're starting to look
like the poorest of the poor in many
ways and so there's some real issues out
there that have been festering for
decades that no one's really paid
attention to that the 2016 campaign for
better of worse at least ripped the
cover off and got us to look but but we
wanted to look deeper and see if we
could come up with some solutions and we
wanted to do in a bipartisan way and we
found that their anger was justified in
some regard the economy's not been
terrific for them what do we think are
some good answers
well there's we can over the range of
answers and our the theme that we have
three dozen answers in our book and the
the common denominator is work we want
to make it we want to make get more
people back into the work force we want
to make work pay we want to give people
the education and skills to get work and
better work and better jobs and we want
to strengthen families and communities
to support work so the solutions range
from unions to childcare to college
financing but the themes the big ideas
are all around work and making work
putting the work back and working class
so let's talk about skills bachelor's
degree good
idea for everybody know and the nation
has been trying to sell college
successfully selling college for all for
two or three decades and what that has
meant is a lot of kids have gone to
college who weren't really going to do
that well in college and it's not
because they're not a smart it's just
because they may be different or the
jobs they want don't need a four-year
college so people are now starting to
realize across the country that maybe
that was the wrong focus I mean if you
can get to college and get through and
succeed and have the right major
four-year college is a great investment
but if you don't get through where you
pick the wrong major very important
choice or you go into debt you're it's
often you worse off at the end so we
give a lot of thought to what could a
true alternative to college be for this
group those in this group who who for
that whom that makes sense and how are
we gonna pay for it because right now
the bulk of federal higher ed financing
goes to traditional academic college and
very little of it just fourteen percent
of it goes to what what I call career
education or occupational education and
you know I don't know exactly what the
balance should be occupational academic
but it's certainly not 1486
and so we gave a lot of thought to how
to to what how the country what policy
should be during a time of national
experimentation which is a tricky
question because if the feds can't
shouldn't just be deciding throw a
billion dollars at this they we have to
be encouraging experimentation and
creating standards but also and also had
to get employers involved as another big
question but then that final you know
hard to wrestle question is where to
find the money so this was one of those
right-and-left coming together we had
six scholars from the left and six
scholars and experts from the right what
did the right agree to that they might
not normally think they would agree to
and what did the left agree to that that
you don't think they would have normally
agreed yeah so the left agree to too
modest work requirements for some
government programs I mean everyone in
the group more or less agreed that the
that the social that the agencies that
administer these programs don't do
enough to get people into the workforce
that mostly they give out the benefits
and they don't do enough to get people
into jobs and everybody was okay with
that with giving the mayor a new mandate
to the agencies to try harder to get
people
into jobs the programs like snap yes
thank you
but where we differed and where a few
people on the Left gave a little ground
was whether we should actually require
people who get benefits to to work or to
do some kind of work activity and you
know eighty-seven percent of the public
I think the number is thinks that that
should be but but there's something left
who think that if you're talking about
Medicaid perhaps or food stamps you
shouldn't have those requirements so
that was it
that was a little movement on the left
on the right we were willing to get that
find a few little tax my pieces
we we focused on tax increases that were
places where people who benefited from
the corporate tax cut you know in the
upper end of the income scale maybe have
benefited I won't say disproportionately
but a lot and we have some modest taxes
they are but a lot of things and this is
this is a lot of our proposals we found
ways to pay for by you know as we used
to call cutting waste and fraud and
misguided spending I mean on the
education front we were just talking
about Education Skills we found in the
double-digit billions by eliminating 529
education savings account for example
which go overwhelmingly to the upper
middle class you know are thinking about
the people that we're thinking about is
there kind of the hole in the doughnut
they're a little too well off to benefit
from many programs that are for the poor
but they don't earn enough or pay taxes
or pay tuition so they don't benefit
from many of the programs for the middle
class and that rain just you know I mean
it's - to some degree the mortgage
interest deduction last but but
certainly education kind of benefits and
childcare benefits and so we want to
even some of that out and so we fell out
in a lot of cases we found the money
that we're gonna spend on the working
class you know there in other places
subsidies for the well-off pretty well
alone
so skills development a little bit of
work requirements in federal programs
that provide assistance without focusing
unemployment what are some of the easy
solutions that some politicians talk
about that we've rejected ah
good very good question because there
are a lot of solutions floating around
out there that sound great and they fit
on your bumper sticker and universal
basic income free
College Medicaid for everybody we said
no we don't like those most of them
would be harmful our solutions are more
practical often they've been I mean you
know let's take an example universal
basic income we think that it should be
universal basic work universal work we
should help everybody to get a job not
give everybody a subsidy to stay home
and then this productive people like us
will work and a lot of other people
won't work and won't have the dignity of
work and so we we rejected these
bumper-sticker solutions and our
solutions you know they can sound wonky
I'll be the first to admit they they
they don't have Muslim don't fit on a
bumper sticker and they need to be
argued through but you know we think
they're practical we think they now have
at least bipartisan buy-in of some kind
many of them have been tested in States
or are being tested in states and many
of them have been floating around on
Capitol Hill and the one we with with
some bipartisan support but the one
reason we couldn't we have been able to
enact them is because people couldn't
agree where to find the money and so for
example I'm the expanding EITC for
childless workers Obama has talked about
that and the Paul Ryan has talked about
that they what they couldn't agree on
was where to find the money we came up
with a bipartisan solution for where to
find the money and one more on what we
didn't choose we didn't choose
protectionism or absolutely trade war no
or or wall at the border or handing
immigration ending immigration and we
and you know we understand that there's
a lot of people in the working class who
feel that who feel or have been told
that immigration is the source of their
problem or have latched on to
immigration as the source of their
problem we don't think it is certainly
not the major source and maybe not even
a significant source and so we thought
we could come up with our solutions that
we think really are real solutions
without going near that very contentious
issue so just describe for me to be
clear who are we talking about what what
exactly exactly
working-class who are they so there have
at least a high school diploma but not a
four-year college degree and they live
in a household the technical the
description is between the twentieth and
fiftieth income percentile what that
means in practice for a household that
has two parents and a child I believe is
between 30 and 70 K
year and the perception in the past was
that someone with a high school degree
but not a college who wanted to work and
participate in the economy could do well
enough to support a family and that's
not true right now globe the
globalization and technology and the way
the country has shifted everything from
everything from policy I daresay where
we just talked about a min ago
middle class and poor getting benefits
upper middle class not these people but
also where investment goes 75 percent of
the venture capital investment goes to
three states so the lot of people in a
lot of places have just been left behind
and they've been left behind materially
economically what-have-you but they've
also been left behind politically nobody
seriously thought about them and tried
to have answers for them or took them
seriously or you know gave them the
dignity I mean I'm not I'm not I'm not
this old but you know in the 50s the
working class of an industrial working
class where the heroes in America the
and would they haven't been the heroes
in America for a long long time and and
so they're hurting in a lot of ways so
work skills community we've talked about
work we've talked about skills we also
asked something of this group as well
don't we we do and community is the
hardest one right because how much can
government reach the community and how
much can you know the the any level of
government what can they do to create
new community and how much can
government really do to repair the urges
and families and those things marriage I
mean some of our really troubling
factual findings marriage has declined
more in in our group than in any other
group over the past 20 years was already
very low for the poor but it's climbed
there but it's declined
nope house is doing pretty well we're in
class down down down and same similar
with single-parent families and
similarly with social you know get
interaction with people in your
community so this is these are they're
not just hurting and that they've had to
go from a $25 an hour factory job to a
$9 an hour Wendy's job they're hurting
because their communities are falling
apart and the the the the bullying the
things that held them together the
churches and the unions and the and all
of those things are afraid are gone and
so it's it's an opiate the opioid crisis
has worked just prayed on you know and
filled in the in the in the crumbling
you know level so you know what can
government do to help that we encourage
people to follow this success sequence
to get a certain amount of education and
get a job and get married before you
have children you know we can't make
anybody do that and we government can't
you know we can't punish people who
don't but we also call on employers to
do employers to do more in that realm we
call it a place to do more in a lot of
realms both that realm childcare also in
getting above and career education you
can't really teach how to prepare for
somebody for a job without knowing what
job you're preparing them for and
talking the employer about it
so we've often the best training takes
place inside employer absolutely our or
with the players cooperating with the
training provider of some kind but um so
and we also so we we struggled with how
to strengthen the communities employers
working-class men and women themselves
families um we were kind of excited
about the potential of Opportunity Zones
new provision in the 2017 Tax Act that
will presumably send some more money out
into these places but we'll only
investment capital but will only work we
think if these places get their act
together to solve some of the other
problems around the around the I'm in my
example is you know the city X is going
to become the 3d innovation hub in
America well that would be great if they
could get some investment to build that
but it won't work if they're not
training people to be 3d in innovation
technicians so so you've led us our
group the six from the left and the six
from the right on on from traveling out
into the country and we went to West
Michigan and that was pretty good role
model what did you see we saw amazing
civic leadership in West Michigan we
went to Grand Rapids and what has
happened in Grand Rapids over the last
20 years is the basically the business
leaders with government you know in
cahoots and social services as well has
come together to say we're gonna make
the city work and we're not gonna wait
for the federal government we're not
gonna go begging Congress we're gonna
put our money where we need to and most
I think important we're going to
coordinate a plan together and come up
with a plan that we then all follow and
you know we saw a city that was just
remarkable in in how what how well
seem to be working we didn't you know
we're there today so there I'm sure
there's some pie there does that that is
part of the solution absolutely and
that's and that's part of what we hope
our thinking around opportunity zones
will generate because can we can we seed
some of that and some other places come
together and make a plan execute it
together and that you know what attracts
so many while you're doing it it was
remarkable community employers
educational institutions working
together to help people get the skills
they need to have higher wages that's
the key right I think that's the key and
I think what might happen this hard part
that we're trying to address which is
families coming back together in
communities forming could happen in that
environment thank you I play hey
everyone that's the end of our
discussion with Tamar Jacoby thanks for
watching and as always let us know what
other topics you'd like AI scholars to
cover on viewpoint and to learn more
about the working class in America check
the links in the description below